every two minutes there's a water main
break somewhere in the country's more
than 2.2 million miles of pipes
according to the American Society of
civil engineers it's just one symptom of
the country's crumbling water
infrastructure lead in the water supply
in Flint Michigan the Water Crisis in
Jackson tonight America's fourth largest
city is under a boil water order but
it's not just the leaking pipes and
contaminated drinking water dams and
levees that protect communities from
severe floods are also at risk so what
are some of the structural factors
driving these problems here's a look at
how Decades of underinvestment brought
America's water infrastructure to a
Tipping Point
foreign
typically Bridges roads and Subways are
funded by federal taxes but not water
infrastructure instead local utilities
are responsible for the operation and
upkeep of community Water Systems this
financing structure can be traced back
to the 1800s when population growth and
industrialization LED U.S cities and
towns to rapidly expand their water
systems for the first time
infrastructure was handled at a local
level not a federal one this led to the
sprawling and highly fragmented nature
of the country's Water Systems there are
over 50 000 utilities that manage just
water up manulal is a director at
Columbia University's Water Center he
has led numerous studies examining the
nation's drinking water and wastewater
systems we either have really big
utilities or thousands of small
utilities the problem is that the
thousands of small utilities really
don't have their technical or financial
capacity to manage things very well
today more than 90 percent of the
average utilities revenues come directly
from local water bills according to
state water directors but there's a
limit to how much money can be raised
through bills to make essential upgrades
rate hikes for instance often have to be
approved by local governments and
factors like a shrinking population mean
the maintenance costs are spread across
fewer rate payers so as a result
especially in communities that have been
declining in population and in
communities of color and communities of
lower incomes there has been a lack of
investment and degradation of the
infrastructure water bills have soared
over the last 10 years along with the
costs to fix problems according to
government data so why is water
infrastructure becoming increasingly
expensive to build and maintain the
simple answer it's too old in 1972
Congress made sweeping revisions to the
federal Water Pollution Control Act or
the Clean Water Act this led to
significant strides in improving water
quality the environmental agenda now
before the Congress includes laws to
deal with water pollution but the
majority of the funding was directed
towards construction of new water
systems rather than the operation and
maintenance of existing systems
but the problem that comes with that is
that what's your plan for when that
infrastructure ages the majority of
wastewater treatment systems constructed
in the 1970s are today reaching the end
of their 40 to 50 year life spans
according to the Environmental
Protection Agency dams are at risk too
the asce found the amount of high Hazard
potential dams has more than doubled in
the last 20 years this means if a dam
were to fail like in the event of an
earthquake or severe storm there would
likely be a direct loss of human life
our dams were designed to have a life of
50 to 70 years with good maintenance
today the median age of U.S dams is 57
years and many pipes are even older on
average they're about 45 years old with
some dating back to the 1800s according
to the asce so essentially two-thirds of
our system is essentially due for
replacement and pipes cost a million
dollars a mile to replace so if you
don't have the million dollars a while
to replace the pipe what you do is you
patch the pipe it then the pie breaks in
another place this becomes like a
Band-Aid approach and so at some point
you just end up with a disaster as as
pipes aged water main breaks and boil
water advisories became more common in
1987 Congress switched from a grant
system to loans specifically State
revolving funds before this federal
grants funded up to 75 percent of state
water projects the logic there perhaps
was that these would be low interest
loans and they would go to communities
that are most in need and the concept
perhaps was that many of the communities
were already taken care of by that point
this meant local communities became
responsible for the majority of project
costs because they were required to
repay the loans the city council will
meet to look over a final design on the
new water treatment plant and decide
whether they should take out a 3.5
million dollar loan to build it while
spending by state and local governments
were on the rise the federal
government's share of water spending
fell by about 69 percent between 1977
and 2017. with limited funds many cities
and towns neglected the repair and
replacement of critical water
infrastructure
the challenge is that if they try to go
for the state revolving fund money
typically they don't have in-house
capacity to develop the proposals needed
so it's not a surprise then that the
smaller utilities that serve poorer
communities often are the ones that are
really unable to come up with ways to
compete for federal funds or to even
compete for products at the right price
point
as Federal funding dried up and systems
aged local governments spent more to
maintain existing water infrastructure
rather than carry out important upgrades
between 1977 to 2017 local governments
spent about 70 percent more on the
operation and maintenance of systems
than on Capital expenses to replace or
install new infrastructure if you look
at how water bills have gone up since
2000 to now they have risen on average
twice the rate of inflation across the
country and most of this is happening
because of the Deferred maintenance
catching up with people in 2021
President Biden signed an infrastructure
bill that sets aside about 55 billion
dollars to improve the nation's aging
Water Systems this law is going to start
to replace 100 percent of the nation's
lead pipes and service lines so every
American every child can turn on the
faucet and drink clean water the Biden
Administration has called it the largest
single investment and clean drinking
water in American history but it only
covers a fraction of the 472 billion
dollar cost identified by the EPA in
2018. still there are varying estimates
for this price tag there is not a
benchmark of this number because we as a
nation we have not done the exercise of
who is in trouble to what extent so how
do you actually Source data from 50 000
different Utilities in a reasonable way
to get an idea of honestly what really
is the need as a main focus of the
infrastructure Bill White House
officials said they are rolling out a
new plan to help 10 million U.S
households replace lead water pipes
[Music]